right strange brigade so a lot of the
personality of the game comes from the
voice-over announcer so I can definitely
recommend at least one headphone
together to catch in
so what's our like backdrop on time
story here what's going on okay so the
game is said 1930s okay and the
atmosphere is kind of like a Saturday
matinee like a serial serial drama that
old-fashioned adventure drama sort of
Aylan it follows the adventures of the
strings Brigade okay globe-trotting find
our adventurers of course find in the UK
but they have members from all around
the world okay so I got like I did set
up all over ya infrastructure going on
yeah so there's adventurers in the
string Brigade to go from all over the
world and they carry the primary
characters here the four coolest
characters that we had there's more
characters in the world even more loads
of the carry
okay this adventure set in tenets of the
Holyrood style of ancient Egypt okay it
looks great oh so we're pretty much
playing cooperative okay so when you
playing treasure you're competing to
grab the treasure when you kill bad guys
they drop Souls and those power up your
amulet or didn't meeting to get their
gadget there's tracks these venture you
can trigger them when your friends are
nearby throw them a little bit so we're
cooperative but with a competitive age -
okay I got you I'm digging out that as
you'll see in a minute for example
here's a puzzle that you complete by
aiming a laser beam on that crystal ball
go ahead oh no it's some mummies Oh No
so it's really uh what are we going to
do so we can chew them up or I can use
it to set farts mummies nice so that
makes them more they'll take more damage
for teammates so they can know i'm
notice you got the aim here going on up
there
yeah so that's that's where you aim it
to solve the puzzle catch it I've pulled
our way just optimizer I can also troll
my teammates a little bit you can do
damage so there's a teammate damage yeah
like we've got it set up so you can do
team that keep damage when you mean to
blow like there's no bullet damage but
it's grenade damage there's laser beams
okay traps you find through the
environment you can trigger on your
friends with gadget so a little bit of
friendly fire yes exactly I got you so
these spinning blades for example
builder damage the teammates so you can
make a find the trigger in them when
your friends are nearby right you can
draw Souls towards yourself quite
holding right trigger going to charge up
there oh now I'm still me each character
has its own specific unique sort of soul
gathering ability yeah different
abilities each curve has got a different
amulet ability and then you can unlock
more for the givers nice nice so one of
my favorites for example is a Gracie who
does a lightning all right little
Palpatine action nice nice so when those
great big cards are bad guys so we got a
little bit of destructible elements
coming to use those to our advantage
against the enemy
taking with melee attack someone on the
ground you can curb stomp let's go yeah
man
so there's a secondary route as well so
you can see the players can find their
own ways through the Advanta you meet up
together they kind of pass out yeah
gotcha
okay cool so we're not like locked into
a set linear we got a couple choices if
you can go as far as route so you can
see here for example like a puzzle right
here and up here there's a load of bad
guys check let's check up there should
be all of the visual cues process behind
the the those type of cues of the game
so I like to shoot video be that kind of
a look
we wanted the whole thing to be nice and
thanks out too seriously exactly so here
we find a workbench you can customize
your weapons or the work thing so for
example we've given all of the
characters a few gems you can try the
demo these let you add damage takes to
your our special properties so for
example I've a chance of doing base
damage
look up and I can speed up my reload or
now how those J those gems are earned
in-game just to later killing it's okay
just all those who do the chest
yeah so the contents that's has to run
them there might be gold there might be
gems they might be carve stone as you
head towards places like this you may
get a jump scare so this might be popped
up on the spring hello
I love the bits of humor yeah so very
kind of light-hearted and fun co-op with
the friends getting it in and also a
little competitive action with competing
each other for our score our souls and
things of that nature
I like the friendly drilling so we've
been rushing through the adventure here
for those loads of secondary routes and
secret options that one didn't have to
shoot me on it
[Laughter]
isn't just a big snack ago okay
a sneak preview of later now that gold
that currency can we can what can we
cash that it was that's actually our
bragging rights what yes there's a few
different options for the you find
prototype weapon crates throughout the
level but those have super powered
weapons in the spring okay so you can
kind of Bank them as well like kind of
Bank gold and not necessarily dodge it
okay that's charging up so if all four
players will gather here in charge the
Romulans they'll trigger the next phase
of the adventure who's not charging
player to our committees like so you guy
gets charged going on man ones focus
you're not playing to area alright okay
new secrets
so there's health potions and all those
traps there's loads of entrances there's
a chance to contains powerful weapons
there we go nice a lot of bad guys
coming through here let's take them out
game was absolutely beautiful tons of
enemies on screen constructive
environment looks like it's just a good
fun with with the cruelty yeah
absolutely you know there's a good fun
light-hearted yeah exactly that take it
too seriously we just having fun out
here yeah Sam shoot left stuff okay to
add a little flavor to it
yeah 1930s British pathé a love it I get
the vibe I can survive on there you took
me there
okay from that chest just in time cuz
here comes some more powerful enemies so
now we lookin like boss fighting now
okay let's get serious
whoo - these guys are gonna try and rush
these and take his art so I'm just gonna
cook them that's right let's get them
see Marcus here an accredited show now
spinning blades in the back like it was
those like traps all right so we kind of
lure them in God okay you can also learn
teammates in in there better friend this
is me with the TV but you control you
did say that you did say you could show
oh no wait let me tell you what's going
on these guys so these guys are armored
enough Spears you got a chip through the
armor to do that they did our cool boss
join the fray oh oh I thought that ghoul
was like one singular entity oh my god
it was introducing a new car - yeah
understood understood
so teammate though so hopefully a
teammate can respond me or one of these
[Music]
myself
okay the work saying good work
I love that bridge there you go nice
got a little cutscenes on
Oh
oh okay it's about you serious now now
we get serious and I'm assuming that's
our big bad strange Begay we're looking
good really fun so it's looking 19:30
cereal of course of course
so what are we looking at at possible
release and platforms will be what are
you looking at so release is August 28th
yes for nice I would possibly shoot like
maybe a 4k for the year for the X for
both alien the progress awesome nice so
we did a pretty good run through their
world a second reposing secrets we
didn't claim unlockables collectibles
we'll find out later playthroughs like I
say denting sell series seems really fun
man I'm actually pretty excited what you
feel same it's like The Mummy meets like
the order and it's like a couple of low
elements going on you know absolutely
absolute legend strange Brigade y'all
I'm diggin it I'm digging that maybe
selling me